we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P here
is a voicemail to wrap up the year.
So riddled with crazy that I don't even know
where to start.
Take a listen.
A prickling.
How's you in the quirky Clinton lowers and
the black Muslim Obama overs?
You know, I'll tell you, you're going to start
a civil war II.
People pick on Trump.
It's going to win unanimously.
A second term close.
He doesn't have a case.
That's why she goes, isn't going to bring
the articles over to the Senate.
Also, you know, you pick on everything.
If it was Obama, the Muslim or crooked Clinton
or Biden, you don't say anything about him.
Don't criticize them.
They're perfect.
They're Jesus reincarnated.
You know, why don't you pick on Lonnie and
next what size, what kind of tampon does she
use?
And what about the skid marks and Barron's
Paty way you people are idiots.
You know, you're a communist in plain English,
and the capitalism is gonna win.
And uh, you know, why don't you go back to
South America where you came from?
You go, where's your little buddy, Patty?
Uh, he's not satisfying your wisdom anymore,
right?
So, listen, we're used
to the homophobia.
We're, we're used to all of that stuff.
Uh, I've heard, go back to South America many
times.
Remember I am a citizen of the United States.
Uh, but also, you know that we don't criticize
Democrats and we criticize Democrats all the
time.
And in fact, I was just, I was just criticized
myself for being critical of the way that
some Democrats are couching certain political
issues.
Uh, I, I love that he says Trump's going to
win unanimously.
That I don't know that they know that this
person knows what that means.
Does unanimous mean that Trump's going to
win every state?
Is Trump going to win any, every vote?
What does that mean unanimously?
Uh, and then again, this idea that I'm a communist,
first of all, uh, that's not true.
And secondly, the idea that the threat is
from communism in the United States is laughable.
There is no threat from communism in the sense
that there is no clamoring to turn the United
States into a communist, uh, state reminiscent
of others that we have seen in history.
So this is who we're fighting since this is
the last voicemail is 2019.
Here's my message that I attached to it.
We can't convince those people to see reason
and come to our side.
So let's not try.
Let's not waste our time.
2020 starts tomorrow.
Let's focus on finding the half of the country
that doesn't vote and getting the people that
already agree with us to understand the importance
of getting out and casting a ballot in 2020
that's it for today.
Pat's got the bonus show today.
I will be back with you on January 2nd to
kick off the David Pakman show, the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com.